les hausses d'impôts pour les plus aisés
sont évidemment une probabilité
importante
il ya différentes façons de payer une
dette soit vous augmentez les impôts
c'est ce qu'il a toujours fait en france
le gouvernement promet de passer par là
évidemment ça ne l'engagent que jusqu'en
2022 ensuite vous avez une autre
une manière qui est de dire on va
essayer de dépenser un peu moins c'est
pas la voix favorite de la france c'est
peut-être qu'il faut essayer de faire
pas tout de suite mais plus tard il est
de redresser un peu les finances
publiques
[Musique]
les hausses d'impôts sommes quand même
une probabilité à moyen terme assez
probable d'autant que les français ont
massivement épargné en plus pendant la
période entre 2020 et 2021
il ya 200 milliards d' épargne
supplémentaire qui vont c'est
l'estimation de la banque de france sur
les comptes en banque et ses 200
milliards on voit bien que ça correspond
au coût donc évidemment l'exécutif rêve
là de ce magot là on peut pas après
c'est très compliqué de trouver pile le
bon système qui permet de prendre juste
c'était parle supplémentaire aux ménages
qui ont accumulé ce tout le monde n'a
pas qu'une aigles épargne certains ont
souffert
donc ce qu'on espère c'est qu'il s'en
vont consommer donc remettre cette
épargne dans l'économie du coup la
croissance va revenir
lectra pour se désendetter par cette
activité c'est le scénario idéal
scénario moins favorable c'est que là la
pandémie reste la croissance est à la
peine il est hausse d'impôts pour les
plus aisés sont évidemment une
probabilité importante